all right am i on
welcome everybody
um it has been a very very uh tough week
from the standpoint of tech
um i'm on the road as many of you know
i'm here with my green screen
there have been so many unforeseen
issues uh audio issues video issues all
sorts of different things i wasn't even
sure whether i was going to be able to
stream and i may not i mean this may be
you guys will have to tell me
um even this stream may completely fall
apart this is supposed to be a
pre-stream for the town hall in 50
minutes that we're doing over on the
pacman live youtube channel
and i don't even know if anything is
gonna hold i really i really don't know
um you can see if i pull down my green
screen
look at that
isn't that something
uh so yeah um it's it's been it's been
very very tough so we're gonna do the
best we can and uh there may be there
may be lagging there may be all sorts of
different elements the other thing is
is super chat even working because
normally on my dashboard i have a
section called viewer activity on
youtube
and
as far as i see super chat is enabled
but that section isn't even there so i
don't even know
if super chat is working at the youtube
level i've never seen this before
uh
yeah i don't know
people can let me know i guess
um
yeah really unclear
really unclear what's going on with that
okay i did get one pretty good remix
from the beans and pasta
thing from the other day
so let's uh oh there is there is a super
chat working that's good let's take a
listen to this let's see if we can even
look at this let's uh let's see
grocery store packed
with lines waiting outside you couldn't
find canned soup you couldn't find black
bean pinto beans kidney beans cannellini
beans refried beans spiced fried beans
you couldn't find fava beans
black beans
oh man we just lost him
that's weird oh and an error occurred oh
my god
well listen while i can
fundamentally what we're what we're
dealing with here is that i need a
different laptop for when i'm on the
road
and i just need someone who can actually
recommend one and i want to be really
clear here let me pause this
i i don't want anybody to write to me
and say you know david you should write
to joe at
at
you know
destiny's laptops and have him custom
built i just need to be able to order
something i can customize it but i can't
be like having to speak to someone on
the phone so if someone genuinely can
recommend a laptop for me that will be
good for being on the road and you have
to understand how many things i have
plugged in
my lights run off of wi-fi
my camera
up here
the microphone i have a second monitor
that i bring with me
um
so it needs to be robust i want 17-inch
i want like the number pad like a
full-size keyboard it could be thick you
know whatever
um so i was looking at like the dell
precision workstation if people feel
strongly about that that's something i
could look at they seem a little bit
you'd go to the grocery store not only
was my grocery store
packed
let's pause that
so in any case if someone can actually
email me
david you might not want a dual stream
on the road now guys i'm s
see this is what i'm talking about
anytime i ask for recommendations
like i'm i just use restream i'm sending
one feed
that's not the source of the issue
like
pl do not email me unless you can
genuinely provide advice as follows
a laptop that would be suitable for
streaming
okay
doesn't require me to speak to someone i
can just customize it like on dell.com
or whatever
a reasonable value okay
um and then i i will get it because
we're going to have some other travel
coming up early in 2022. we've got to do
it we've got to do it so info
davidpakman.com
and you don't recommend an apple i'm on
pc
um and let's just you know let let's
let's do this seriously recommend a
specific laptop for me these these
really seem okay like this precision
5760
um
i don't know much about the rtx a2000 i
have to say i don't know about that
starts at five pounds i'll carry around
five pounds you know so okay anyway let
me know info davidpakman.com and that
would be really really useful something
seems up with youtube here
so um
yeah i don't know if we're even gonna be
able to play that it's sort of sort of
hectic i did have this meme for you i
don't even really get this this is
pac-man i guess as opposed to pokemane
and it also says obama it's some kind of
album cover
and it looks like stephen kenneth
destiny bennell the second
on on the shirt that i'm wearing so that
was an interesting meme
that was sent to me yeah guys i don't
need a business laptop i just need a
laptop that will be good for streaming
okay that's it's it's quite simple quite
frankly
uh we did get a super chat that came in
hard to beat lenovo for what you're
talking about okay fair but it would be
great to get a specific recommendation
specific recommendation
uh of a particular one
see what else people had to say via
super chat
uh not too too much massive streaming
dumps oh speaking of which we did have
uh a michael cohen interview today
website members would already know about
it they would already be able to see it
um in the in the member control panel of
the website interviewed michael cohen he
i am going to announce he did use the
term
massive dumps during the interview
and he also asked me whether it's
pronounced laura ingram or laura
ingraham so it became very clear during
the interview that michael cohen knows
the lingo and he watches the david
pakman show so that was very very
exciting to see
um
and that is already live
on the website
for our members the eggman called in
about it let's take a listen
dave i love michael cohen so much
i can't say it enough i love him so much
i could listen to you interview him all
day all night it's the greatest feeling
ever to hear you two guys talk i'm
[ __ ] giddy listening to you guys he
might replace you as my favorite jew
now how long did it take pat to believe
that whole interview
god i love that interview i love that
man is it wrong
is he tricking me and making me like him
uh shalom brother shalom michael cohen
you're [ __ ] great keep it up brother
yeah in fact i know that eggman is
joking
michael cohen's swearing delayed the
show today
pat sent me a message let me see exactly
how he said it hold on this was so funny
there were so many bleeps
pat said um
oh this was so funny
member content will be late due to the
bleeping yeah michael cohen dropped
about maybe 15 or 20 swears during the
interview and as a result he
single-handedly delayed the publication
of today's
uh not a joke
not a joke folks not a joke whatsoever
okay
let's do one more attempt
of the beans and pasta remix because it
is really good and guys listen i'm not
taking specific laptop recommendations
in the chat if you genuinely know what
you're talking about on laptops that
would be good for streaming email info
davidpakman.com because i can't you know
research laptops while streaming let's
give this one more attention foods you'd
go to the grocery store not only was the
grocery store
packed
with lines waiting outside you couldn't
find canned soup you couldn't find black
bean pinto beans kidney beans cannellini
beans refried beans spiced fried beans
you couldn't find fava beans
black bean pinto beans kidney beans
cannellini beans refried beans spiced
fried beets you couldn't find fava beans
black beans pinto beans kidney beans
cannellini beans refried beans with
spiced rice
you couldn't find fava beans
black beans pinto beans kidney beans
cannellini beans refried beans with
spiced rice you can find fava beans
okay i could go on i'm all right so
that's that
that's one part where that could be a
clip for itself
okay okay and then here is another part
where you guys tell me whether this
should be a clip the dry pasta
no spaghetti no ziti no penne no goku no
pepper nelly nope rotini linguine angel
hair cabbage tagliatelle pusili macaroni
configure you couldn't find the lasagna
noodles guys okay
uh all right so you can find black beans
pinto beans
cannellini beans refried beans with
spiced rice you can find fava beans
black beans
you can find fava beans
black beans pinto beans kidney beans
beans refried beans with spice rice you
can find fava beans black bean pinto
beans kidney beans cannellini beans
refried beans with spiced rice you can
find fava beans
i could go on i'm big on beans as you
can tell
there you go so a very very powerful
remix there coming to us extremely
strongly um so that is that
uh let's see what else we've got here
for people just joining us i know that
there's all sorts of tech issues i'm on
the road with a dramatically
underpowered laptop i am looking for
recommendations for a new laptop for
streaming from the road
if you have
specific recommendations info
davidpakman.com would very much
appreciate it okay a lot of you want me
to weigh in on this issue
of
hassan destiny
[ __ ] ii
being banned from twitch for using a
certain word that i'm not going to say
that relates to white people
um i guess then ian vausch was also
banned from twitch now i'm not gonna say
the word because you know
the last thing i need is another twitch
ban
here is my view on that and i've said
this before
um
it is not a word
that i use
it is not a word i recommend anyone use
the debate over whether or not one can
be racist against white people
is really more of an academic debate in
terms of how you define racism is it
prejudice plus power or not and all of
this other thing it's not really
interesting to me my view is
anyone can be racist and anyone can be
the victim of racism in a general sense
i don't use any of those words there's a
word that is the spanish word for a worm
which is applied generally speaking to
white
latinos like me
don't use the word i think it's a it's a
racially
uh loaded word
i don't use the n-word i don't use other
words uh it's just
it just of cour and and i don't know if
at all
hassan did this on purpose to get
himself banned to prove a point i don't
really i don't know anything about it
but
it's not a good word to be using it's a
pejorative about white people it sees it
it groups people by their race
and so i'm not going to use it and it's
not a word that i i would use
is it exactly equivalent to the n-word
i don't know guys it obviously doesn't
have the same loaded history as the
n-word i wouldn't deny that
uh white people were not enslaved in the
way black people were
with this word used on top of it the way
the n-word was so you know if we want to
kind of have a
an oppression olympics i think the
n-word comes out ahead
but it's just another pejorative word
that categorizes people by race
so it's it's just there's nothing
progressive about using it there's
nothing progressive about using it and
you know public private whatever it's
just no and i would say
i would say it to hassan i would say it
to ian vausch i would say it to whoever
i don't know where ethan klein is on it
but i think there's uh some some aspect
of that
uh okay
let's um
yeah i'm being told that
the video quality is just a disaster
well let's deal with it as much as we
can let's deal with it as much as we can
i want to say thanks to danny thompson
who says via super chat been a while
since i've been able to send a super
chat and join a live stream so what
better time than when you are having
technical problems uh thanks for all you
do yeah maybe for the for the town hall
what i'll do is turn down even more
the uh
the bit rate maybe that would be
something to look at
i don't know if that would help or not
okay and then oh sorry and so let's look
at this this is a uh this is a crazy
situation here i wanted to play this for
you guys this is carrie lake supporter
ethan schmidt pulling his mask off at a
native american convenience store which
of course they have jurisdiction there
uh let's take a look at this
there is no mandate for a mess
your policy does not supersede the law
it's against my religion and i have a
health condition i can't wear a mask
isn't that the best it's like it's
against my religion and i have a health
exemption to this like wow so you
definitely aren't wearing one huh you're
breaking the law by if you're trying to
refuse service you're breaking the law
in your service you're more than welcome
to go through a driver
they can assist you in the driveway yes
they're disgusting disgusting behavior
[Music]
wow these people are so sick
so sick
just need this right here
so hopefully you guys don't break the
law the cashiers can't serve you why
it's only going to take you two seconds
you know you know what country is this
this is indian country this is america
you don't have to wear a mask in america
read this
hey guys you guys you guys approve of
this
do you approve of this you approve of
discrimination
oh 100
100 discrimination
100 discrimination
your policy is not above the law dude
your policy is not above the law bro no
it is especially
this concept of above the law or not
it's like well it's less about being
above the law or not it's just does the
policy violate any law and the answer is
no you guys are just killing yourself by
wearing mass all day
disgusting
unbelievable behavior
do you like you like being a little nazi
do you really like it
does it give you power to try to enforce
mass i do this all the time dude i hunt
mass nazis dude
i have people who don't want to win this
you don't even have it put it over your
nose in if you're going to wear a mess
yeah do that slave
be a good slave put it down be a good
slave no put it down now go
oh i need 20 i'm pumped too oh you ain't
going to get surface here if you don't
want to wear the mask then don't
go in
look at this guy nazi this is a nazi
this is a modern day fashionista
you're disgusting dude this is how you
treat your customers no just go ahead
fine dude
there you go
oh my god so that got that got very very
serious very quickly um and then the
other thing i had for you guys this is
really funny someone sent to me this
website which is an archive of trump sir
stories
and it's it's a pretty genius website
now it hasn't been updated since october
of last year i guess they stopped
updating it sort of towards the end of
uh trump's presidency but this is like
really really good
uh we're going to look at it in a second
let me just see here if i i don't want
to
miss anybody else here
ritz brand or keebler salted crisps i
prefer the back to nature there's a back
to nature harvest
um
product
which is uh three ingredients i believe
it's whole wheat flour canola oil and
salt
whole wheat flour canola oil and salt
and that's my preference
um you know i don't want any of these
other
adulterating agents okay check this out
so here's trump's stories these are so
good
it's great that these are archived um so
here's one this is the the infamous sir
story about ammunition
so we now have 10 000 and we inherited a
system which was broken just like i'll
never forget the day when a general came
in and said sir my first week in office
we have no ammunition
that was in the military we've now
rebuilt our military stronger than it's
ever been and we have so much ammunition
very good
um another story
we invested 2.5 trillion in the united
states military we have the greatest
equipment any nation has ever had when i
came a highly overrated general told me
sir we have no ammunition
we maybe had to do something we have no
ammunition sir
let's pick another one
they say it's the greatest plane in the
world and by the way speaking of that
our military when i came in the world's
most overrated general told me sir we
have no ammunition
because we may have a con have had a
conflict very early in what is this guy
even talking about
uh let's do another one
i want to do like a non-ammunition one
oh these are all about ammunition
hold on can i find one that's a
non-ammunition story
now this is who knows what website i'm
even on this is crazy
yeah so oh i see ammunition let me close
that out there we go okay
oh these are some good ones
and you also see where your friends are
going to the hospital and you say how is
he doing
two days later they say sir he's
unconscious or he's in a coma i remember
that i streamed that press briefing
where trump did that
let's look at another one
now when i said go to the church i
didn't know protesters or not nobody
tells me that they say yes sir we'll go
to the church
man these are wild these are all lies
right like none of these stories are
true
it's like a page too
oh yeah that's a good idea let's see if
i search for sync or let's see if i
search for toilets
if anything will come up
oh my god look at this it's here
oh my god this is it
we won't talk about toilets but you know
that's 10 15 but we don't talk about
that because i've said this three or
four times the only subject they ever
talk about is toilets so i don't mention
but how about the shower
you go into a shower and i have this
beautiful head of hair i need a lot of
water i need water you go into the
shower right you turn on the water drip
drip drip i called the guy something
wrong with this no sir it's just the
restrictor so you're in there five times
longer than you're supposed to be
oh man let's see what about flushing
or just flush
no nothing on flush what about sink
these are fascinating
full sync
yeah here it is oh who cares about that
very big stuff these are big things a
lot of people have come up thank you sir
they had sinks that didn't give water
they had showers that didn't give water
man that is wild
that is wild
uh what about like cases let's see if
cases gives us anything coveted related
no not there
no these aren't good
oh this is a genius one i remember this
one too and cases are up why are cases
up because we test more than anybody in
history i mean we have tests on top of
tests we'd like another test we got 19
different versions and we test much more
than india they have 1.5 billion people
and many countries don't test at all
many countries don't test at all but we
test more but deaths are way down and
people are getting better but i'm an
example of it my wife is an example of
it first lady and barron trump young
very young 14 he's my very tall 14 year
old boy he's tall he's a tall guy but
he's a strong guy and he tested the
doctor said sir baron is tested positive
i said positive for what
said covet i said oh that's terrible oh
no he'll be okay like 15 minutes later
how's baron doing doc oh it's okay he's
fine now they have strong immune
these are just insane
let's see if there's any other covet
case ones
let's look at maybe china virus or maybe
even just virus
this is my favorite website i have to
tell you
yeah i remember this as well and you see
and you also see where are your oh wait
is this this this one's different right
no this is the one i read before okay
how did that work out sir we just set a
new record oh this one is genius yeah
but that was something to watch and i
had no idea we walked back i said so how
did that work out they said sir you just
set a new record and the history of the
stock market so that was pretty good
[Laughter]
this is insane
oh he's done the sir he's in a coma
thing a bunch of times i see
wow this is a gold mine
but i've lost five people that i know
two people were very good friends of
mine and you call up two days later how
are they doing sir they're in a coma i
said they're in a coma now they were
older i wouldn't say they were the
greatest of health i wouldn't say their
weight was perfect not perfect but
they're gone so it's just a terrible
terrible thing man this is really the
mother lode
i'm not aware of any website as
interesting as this let's just go to
like a random one
let's pick number uh oh i don't know how
about number 21 yeah
and we had these calls with governors
mike pence heads up the task force he
did a great job we have great
professionals and we took this thing and
we have all the governors usually 50
governors on the line at one time and
they're always sir you've a great job
thank you very much great job great job
great job your governor's down i mean
it's all down
thank you very much you've done a great
job on behalf of michigan i'd like to
thank you
then she goes out speaks to the press
we're very unhappy with the president my
god
the ammunition story of course
all right i guess we can we can drop it
but this is this really is just the best
brian they have it wait wait wait just
one thing so they have it because i said
how much of the farmers lost because of
china targeting
sir 16 billion and 12 billion the
previous year
what a wild situation oh wow look at
this
four sirs here
i did make the commencement address and
the general said sir would you like to
shake hands with the cadets
i said does everyone else do it
president oh yes sir
what he didn't say is they'll shake 10
hands i said so they do how many do you
have
sir we have 1156 cadets i said you mean
other people do it yes sir but they
don't do 11 56 they do 30 40.
i said i'll do it all right
wow what what an incredible website this
is richie lionel dot github dot io and
it's a sub page called president trump
sir stories president trump sir stories
that's the website
uh okay everybody thank you very much
uh all right what else do we have here
oh a couple voicemails sure yeah let me
do the voicemails
get off of this
see what we've got the the voicemails
have actually been completely toxic
lately
i don't even know if i want to do it
but uh
here's like i think this is a troy york
one
uh yes i think that your video
on um
laura ingram is um
and trump's interview on laura ingram is
the line um
trump said nothing but the truth and you
twist it
and you accuse him of being a liar when
in fact
um
you are the liar
and um
gas prices have gone up
just kind of free association
total free association there
let's see just because it's been so long
let's see if we can hear anything from
uh from like whitney or some of our some
of our favorite callers we are up to 865
unlistened to voicemails at this point
in time
so it could take some time to kind of
get through it all
for lack of a better term
let's see what we've got
it is
the the voicemail box is exploding it's
insane what's going on quite frankly
completely bonkers
oh by the way thanks to
we're having such tech issues
thanks to everybody subscribing via
twitch prime um m frazzled and guitar
goddess pac fans
jen here is gifting subs and neptune all
these great people high hall polo dal
it's just really really great people
also thanks to everybody signing up on
my website i see a bunch of people did
uh
wow
i appreciate it
let's see who we've got here
oh no i'm told the lag is really really
bad you know what let's do this since
since the um since the live town hall is
starting at the top of the hour
let me end this stream now and reduce
the bit rate a little bit so we can so
we can get some smoother streaming at
the top of the hour
the town hall is going to be on pacman
live okay so let's